if the question is deciding which to
write for it's what is it that you want
to write
how fast do you have to write a
television script versus a movie script
generally if you're on the staff of a
show
from the time that your outline is
locked now we're talking about a process
until you get
that outline done so there's been a
pitch there's been a story discussion
there's been a structuring there's been
an outline there's been a revised
outline
so
starting from that moment which is at
that point weeks in uh you might have
two weeks or three weeks to write a
script
depending on the show
that's the traditional rhythm
but there are shows that uh package up
entirely before they ever shoot and if
they're gonna do a whole season in
advance you might have more time a movie
script if it's if you're doing it on
your own
take the rest of your life if you want i
mean who cares um
but again if you're working for a
producer who has commissioned it you
will have a deadline the deadline might
be
depending on
the nature of it you might have a month
or two
uh
but i find that students especially
uh writing first scripts
need much longer my students who write
scripts at usc might take an entire
semester of four months
to finish a draft and then another
semester of another three or four months
to polish that draft
that's luxurious and it's because
they're students and they're getting
feedback
if you work at that pace in the industry
i think they'd be considered very slow
and is that something that your students
are very aware of that it is actually
you're giving them more time than maybe
they would have had they be yeah no they
know
they know and they're um
you can tell them but that's different
it's one thing to be told it's another
thing to be in in the midst of the world
where somebody says okay go home i want
to see our first draft in two weeks
and you know are they going to panic
they shouldn't panic if they have if
they have the tools that they've been
given you can you can easily do an hour
and two weeks
my
when i was doing those kinds of things
my pace
was always that i would
if you think of an hour as being
maybe 28 scenes maybe less
depends
um
and if you think about it if you write
two scenes per day
and that's not very much really that's
you know
maybe
four to six pages per day it's all your
writing
but if you do that
for two for 14 days
just
at just even two scenes per day
you've got your 28 scenes in two weeks
and you could do it faster
so it's not it's not a burdensome
schedule really at all
how does a writer decide if their story
will be more effective as
a film or a television series
all stories that
mean
something to audiences
are based on human beings
there is no
storytelling that is not character
driven
so the special effects
approach
uh whether that's superheroes or fantasy
action adventure
might be fun
for a
big screen
and the audience which tends to be
adolescent boys
and if
what you want to write
is a special effects laden uh
fantasy action adventure
uh or any other kind of um
big action panorama you're much better
off with the movie
if that's what you want to do
but if what you
want to write are stories involving
human beings and their relationships and
their issues whether that's personal or
political or
whatever it is
or historical or contemporary uh if it's
based from character
uh i don't think you're going to find
a lot of
takers
in the
movie industry
on the studio level
because what used to be small films or
personal films
or
or
dramas character dramas
are not easy to finance because they
don't know how they're going to make
their money back unless of course maybe
you have a big star involved but even in
that case
the star
world is no longer what it used to be
there aren't movie stars
that can drive a box office like they
used to be
so i really think that um
[Music]
if if the question is deciding which to
write for it's what is it that you want
to write
so you don't think that there's a modern
day cary grant i mean we just watched uh
no
i don't i mean there are names that you
would know i mean tom cruise is
currently
uh
being called the last movie star because
he's trying to you know reboot his you
know his flying movie top gun
from the 1980s
i guess 1980s it was yeah
more than 30
about 30 years ago or so um
we'll come see him now because they're
recapturing their youth i don't know how
many of those people are going to the
movies honestly
if you look at somebody like zendaya
which is uh
from euphoria on hbo
now she has a following now she had a
following first as a musician
before she did as an actress and then
euphoria is capturing
a certain feeling about high school life
which is
not
not accurate and i have my own ideas
about like euphoria but nonetheless it
is very successful and she is a star
but she's a star that did not ever
work in movies
uh she's a television star and a big
star and a bigger star than many of the
other names you might see out there
there are wonderful people who are still
around jane fonda for example and lily
tomlin doing that wonderful
grayson frankie that's television
sure sure and that was based off a movie
wasn't it was there
i don't remember the origin of it but um
a lot of things that are on television
are based on books or on uh
international materials
has film versus television evolved
further from each other
as time has gone on let's say it's how
the popularity of streaming has emerged
and then the cinema experience for
whatever reason has maybe gone away
the cinema experience has certainly uh
changed with the closure of theaters
that's partly pandemic related
and it's partly financial
and it's partly that why go spend that
much money for the tickets and the
parking and the dinner
and the babysitter if that's something
that you know happens to you um
when you could wait a few weeks and
it'll be on netflix or amazon or
something else
so i think that the
i noticed that nearby the
landmark theater
just closed in uh in the west side
pavilion
so exhibition theaters are really
getting to be more like uh
theaters for plays
where there's special events
uh or or theaters for concerts special
events where you know you're going out
for the night and you're spending a lot
of money because it is an experience
on the other hand
the opportunities for exhibition on
television have increased of movies
so
in that sense they're coming together
the only thing is there is a difference
of the viewing experience between
something in a dark theater on a large
screen
and something on your home screen or
even your computer screen
televisions and homes in terms of
convergence
many theater screens got smaller for a
while
so that you could have
you know smaller theaters in multiplexes
at the same time as television home
television screens got bigger so they're
almost the same size almost the same
experience
that's changing a bit now as the small
screen multiplexes are
going away they're just not a
much of a business model
and more and more people are watching on
their computers
even on their phones if you're watching
something whether it's a movie or a
television show on your phone it's a
very different experience because uh the
kind of information you're getting on a
screen that size is different and it
tends to complement
the experience of intimacy with a
character and
be not good for panoramic storytelling
although i have to say personally
nothing beats like a sunday
matinee with maybe three people in the
theater well that's wonderful but
imagine it from the uh
the theater owner's point i understand
those three people are not paying his
rent i know in fact they're probably a
drain on there or probably a negative uh
well they're closing for that reason
yeah it's a it may be luxurious
in the same sense as any private
screening is luxurious
uh
if you talk to the theater owners
association they'll they're
all in woe
sure
yeah hopefully though some somehow we
figure out a way or it becomes
fashionable again in some sense well i
think it it
will always be there as an experience in
the same sense as going to theater going
to a concert
but that puts
the pressure on uh showing blockbusters
or special events of some sort and it
makes it even harder
on the small independent personal film
which will have
you know very very little in the way of
an audience so
uh
so those films will do fine
on television because actually
if you're dealing with the small
personal indie film that tends to be
character driven anyway well that's what
television is
and there's no reason that people can't
uh tune in for something that is just 90
minutes long and they do
your book right here this is something
that's required reading for some of your
students oh
it it's required reading throughout the
industry i sometimes go into
offices and i find this on executive
desks and sometimes
i've heard that the mentorship programs
for developing
new writers on on television
are requiring this for
the mentees coming in and yes my
students all read this at usc uh it's
it's kind of the bible of the industry
for how to write for television
and uh this is the fourth edition
uh the reason
it's the fourth edition is that
television keeps growing and changing uh
the very first edition of this book
came out in 2005
i think and you can imagine how
different the world was that was before
streaming
and it was out of date on publication
uh
and
every few years i do another version
this is the end of 2018 and after this
more has happened so this book has
everything in it
great yeah so when you were writing it i
guess netflix was mailing out dvds no uh
2018 uh
it was after that
oh oh i'm i meant the for i'm sorry i
should oh
earlier one no and
netflix wasn't even mailing them out at
the time
the only thing in 2005 uh there were
still the the uh ford legacy networks is
all uh plus hbo
and hbo uh had only been in business you
know four or five years
amc was doing some very interesting
things
but breaking bad hadn't yet come on
and
everything everything changed after that
everything changed there was a four act
structure required in 2005 of uh
everything and that has changed so the
world has moved on uh in in
fascinating ways